she just went through a pretty public
breakup did you give her any advice
y'all got to be careful how I answer
this Steve Harvey's tight-lipped when it
comes to dating advice he's giving his
daughter Lori following her split from
Michael B Jordan he's very different Man
Steve appeared on today with Hoda and
Jenna Tuesday morning and while he
admitted he can't say much about his
daughter he shared how helping her
navigate this new season of her life is
difficult I've given her advice quite a
few times but you know it's difficult
because she's 25 she's growing up in as
a public figure she doesn't get to make
her mistakes like everybody else
everybody else get to make their
mistakes in the cloak of Darkness at
your house hers gets publicized but
she's done a really good job of figuring
it out and getting it right yeah Lori's
getting it right all right she Graces
the January February cover of essence
Magazine's black love issue representing
self-love she told the mag I feel like
it's always been about me attached to
something or someone this time it's
about me self-love self-care
self-reflection I'm being a little
selfish right now it's my my time I
think that's a great place for her to
start I love how she said in essence
like she was going to be selfish and
that shouldn't be taken the wrong way
it's like I'm looking out for me what
the things I need things that fulfill me
that sounds like a page from your well
but you know that's for women though
yeah you get the best out of a man and
out of life when you get the best out of
yourself Lori's selfish era comes after
her breakup with Michael B Jordan last
June after dating for a year what does
Michael B Jordan find very sexy a nice
smile and alive and a sense of humor is
uh is really sexy to me well I see why
you found who you found then because she
she has all of those all of those things
she's actually very funny a lot of
people don't know that about it yeah
it's really funny yeah when it comes to
their split A source told E.T at the
time the two were at different stages in
their lives and months after their split
Lori chatted with Tiana Taylor on an
episode of bumble's love to see it
series opening up about her current
mindset when it comes to dating okay I'm
about to like I said just date on my
terms and like however I want to move
whatever I want to do I'm gonna do it
and if it's no longer serving me I'm
gonna move on
[Music]